If you want to hear by theory on how a couple
of familiar characters might have played a
hand in the ending of Annabelle Comes Home,
then stick around to the end of this video.
It’s been a long journey spanning over several
movies, but Annabelle is finally coming home.
Today on Things You Missed I’m covering
the third movie of the Annabelle subset, Annabelle
Comes Home.
And it starts with the nurses.
AGAIN.
We’ve seen this exact conversation included
in The Conjuring, Annabelle and now Annabelle
Comes Home.
At least this time we get to see what happens
after that.
Ed takes the doll as he and Lorraine begin
a long drive home.
Lorraine says they might get lost and she’ll
wake up in California, that could also be
a reference to the fact that the Annabelle
doll was in California in the last movie chronologically,
or maybe a clue that they’ll be headed there
in the future.
The car breaks down near a cemetery, and Ed
hops out to inspect it.
Lorraine hears a voice say, “I like your
doll”.
Annabelle Higgins, also known as Janice, says
this exact line when breaking into John and
Mia’s home in Annabelle.
"I like your dolls."
One of the things I’ll be talking about
in this video is how the demon that is attached
to the Annabelle doll learns new tricks from
each home he stays in.
Imitating the Higgins adopted daughter is
just one of them.
As the pastor from The Conjuring helps Ed
and Lorraine secure the doll, a number of
supernatural occurrences take place, one of
which is the clocks moving backwards.
Much later on in the film, the character Danielle
sees a TV screen that shows a feed of her
a couple seconds into the future.
So I’m thinking that time manipulation could
be a new ability that the demon, Malthus,
has picked up.
This may or may not be related to Lorraine’s
ability to see past and future events, as
showcased in The Conjuring 2, or the TV that
seems to show programs related to what’s
about to happen next in the original Annabelle.
Judy’s babysitter Mary Ellen goes to the
grocery store to prepare a cake for her birthday
and at the end of one of the isles there is
a comic book display with four covers that
we can see, Swamp Thing, The Demon, Detective
Comics and Batman.
The Demon is obviously there because the antagonists
of The Conjuring Universe are demons, but
another interesting note is that all four
comics are DC. James Wan, who directed The
Conjuring 1 and 2 and David F Sandberg, who,
as you know, directed Annabelle: Creation,
both went on to make DC comic book movies.
I haven’t seen these movies, but I have
heard they sometimes link back with an Annabelle
reference.
Mary Ellen’s friend Daniela shows up at
the house and finds a bell, and she asks if
this is a spirit bell.
When the spirits are unleashed later, all
the bells ring like crazy.
This is one of those tricks that Malthus picked
up over the years.
In Annabelle: Creation, Esther Mullins is
bed ridden and uses a similar bell to request
help, which the demon takes advantage of to
scare these two girls.
When Daniela sneaks into the Warren Artifact
Room for the first time everything we will
come to know about the lore of this movie
is setup.
Outside of Malthus, there are, at the very
least, three other spirits from the Warrens’
past cases that are set free.
Daniela touches the book on the The Black
Shuck, which if you don’t know the legend
is a ghostly black dog that could be found
in the UK.
Some have said it’s a demon, some have said
it’s an omen of death.
It’s not clear if the book is the artifact
in this case, or the taxidermied dog seen
in the background, but I’m guessing it’s
the book, because that’s what she touches.
In the study later, when they are snooping
into the case files, it refers to the Black
Shuck as a hellhound from St. Mary’s Cemetery
in England.
Later we see the box that the info from this
case is kept in, and the label says February
1966, which predates both The Conjuring and
Annabelle.
Another object she touches is the bag of coins.
The case file we later see for this is a case
called The Fairy Man.
OK, I was kidding when I said they should
make a Conjuring movie on the tooth fairy,
but turns out they’ve gone ahead and pulled
it off.
This one is an ancient Greek legend about
the mythological Charon said to ferry the
souls of the dead away from the land of the
living.
The coins seen over the eyes of all the victims
are a reference to Charon’s obol, and it
was seen as a bribe for him to carry over
the soul and prevent it from drifting back
to the world of the living.
When Daniela later invades the case file for
this, she shows a picture of a victim that
looks like Mary Ellen and says they could
be sisters -- this is the doppelganger like
woman in the coffin that Mary Ellen must pry
the Annabelle doll away from at the end.
Then, there’s the wedding dress, and thought
its not said by name in Annabelle Comes Home,
it’s based on the legend: The Haunted Wedding
Dress of Anna Baker.
This legend is about a girl from the 1940s
who met a bitter and miserable death after
her father didn’t allow her to marry the
man who she’d fallen in love with.
Judy explains that this dress haunts people
and causes them to become violent, which is
what happens later that night to Daniela,
after the ghost of the bride pins her and
does that throw up black substance in her
mouth thing -- the same thing that got Janice
possessed in Annabelle: Creation.
So other than Malthus, those are the main
three evil spirits that get released in Annabelle
Comes Home, but there a few others that I
believe got out as well -- some of which you
may find familiar.
Once Malthus is out, bad things start to happen.
That afternoon someone knocks on the door,
Mary Ellen opens it to find that it’s Bee,
the deceased daughter of Mr. and Mrs. Mullins
from Annabelle: Creation and the form that
the demon uses to trick them later on.
One of the notes left for the girls says “Miss
me?”
Later on when Daniela is back in the Artifact
Room, the typewriter says “Miss me” over
and over.
The idea of leaving notes comes from Bee,
who used to leave her Dad notes when she wanted
to play Hide and Seek, and the phrase miss
me, is something that the demon used to terrorize
the nurses from the opening of The Conjuring.
The scene where Judy is attacked by the Wedding
Dress Woman in her room is very reminiscent
of a scene from The Nun, where the demon circles
around the outside of the room, then appears
and charges forward.
Whenever she walks by a picture frame, she
causes it to fall, but when she walks by the
cross, it flips over into a Satanic cross.
Later on, if you pay attention to the game
show on the TV, the contestant is a young
girl who wins a Raggedy Ann doll, so the actual
doll that the Annabelle doll is based on continues
the streak of appearing as an easter egg in
each movie.
That night after Judy is in bed, Daniela heads
home, but realizes she still has the keys
to the Warrens’ Artifact Room, so she sneaks
back in to try to contact her father one more
time.
She thinks she’s made contact, but it’s
really just the demon posing as her father
to scare her.
When it screams at her, the form of her dad
is missing one eye, perhaps another trick
that Malthus picked up from Esther Mullins
that he adds to his arsenal.
Meanwhile, Mary Ellen pours herself a glass
of milk, which the demon promptly destroys.
We get it dude!
You don’t like skim!
The Ferryman also starts to torment her, by
rolling a bunch of coins at her?
Wow man, I wish my demons gave me free money.
But things get real when she sees the two
coins near the ceiling on the dark, because
anyone who’s seen the original Annabelle
may know that this is how Malthus sneaks up
on you by climbing on the ceiling and the
pouncing down on you.
This is about when the air yeeting begins.
Mary Ellen gets Air Yeeted across the floor
downstairs, and Judy is fast asleep upstairs.
Before I mentioned that there may be another
familiar spirit that gets released from the
Artifact Room, because the way that Judy gets
pulled down on her bed is very reminiscent
of the attacks issued by Bathsheba -- the
witch that the Warrens defeat in The Conjuring.
"It's not funny anymore, I'm trying to sleep,
please don't pull my feet."
But that isn’t all, because the music box
that Bathsheba is stored inside appears in
the climax scene in the study, where it can
be seen sitting in the background before somehow
appearing back in the Artifact Room at the
end of the movie.
But back to Judy’s room for a moment -- the
light projector is knocked down and four shadows
appear on the wall, one for each color of
light.
The first is the shape of the Annabelle doll,
then Bee, then the adult Annabelle Higgins
and the last one is Malthus, which is the
first we see of him in his true form during
this movie.
As I mentioned, Malthus has picked up some
alternate forms and tricks along the way,
from the farmhouse in Annabelle: Creation,
to the apartment in Annabelle, to the nurses’
home in The Conjuring, but apparently he’s
also been to the Wizarding World of Harry
Potter, because when he tries to suck out
Judy’s soul through her face, which is exactly
how the Dementors suck your soul out in Harry
Potter.
Together, the three girls are able to contain
the evil once again, but before I end this
video, I have one more lingering question
I’d like to answer.
The whole idea of this movie is that Judy
has this young babysitter that makes the mistake
of letting a friend open up the Artifact Room
-- but what happened Judy's Grandmother that
stays over and takes care of her in The Conjuring?
"Mom it's me, is Judy OK?
Can you go check please?
**** Mom just check, please!!"
"You gonna tell me what's going on?"
"No!"
We know Annabelle Comes Home takes place between
The Conjuring and The Conjuring 2, because
the music box that they acquired at the end
of the first one is there on the shelf, but
the toy they acquired from The Conjuring 2
isn’t there yet.
Actually it doesn't 100% make sense because
this scene takes place in '68, so I think
the one year later text in Annabelle Comes
Home just means one year after The Conjuring.
So Annabelle Comes Home must take place in
1971 or 1972.
So what happened to Georgiana in that one
year?
It’s possible they just fired her after
this whole incident took place.
"Judy!"
"Nana!"
"Judy open the door!"
"Mom!!"
"Judy!"
"Help!"
"Judy, open up--"
"What is it?"
"What's going on in there?"
...but I like to think they were still on
good terms.
Georgiana was getting up there in age, and
it’s possible that she could have passed
on.
Maybe her ghost is still present in the house.
It’s never explained in Annabelle Comes
Home what caused Judy to overcome her fear
of ghosts, giving her the courage to follow
the spirit of Father Michael Morrissey (that’s
the guy she sees that her school) in order
to recover the key and get back the Annabelle
doll -- but she does reiterate a line that
Mary Ellen had told her earlier: “maybe
not all ghosts are bad.”
I like to think she might have realized this
by encountering or remembering Georgiana’s
ghost somewhere along the way.
That wraps up this trilogy of Things You Missed
in Annabelle, but click the playlist on the
left to see my other Conjuring Universe episodes.
And, we’ve got a new mainline Conjuring
movie on the way very soon -- so make sure
you’re subscribed to CZsWorld for new horrors
every week, ring that deathbell for notifications
and I’ll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.